I want to talk today about
monetary policy. And, um,
first of all I wanted to just review some
thoughts about Carl Icahn who spoke on
Monday. Uh, I thought he
was very amusing. Uh, I,
um,
am again happy that you ask questions
cause that's when you bring out a speaker
really well. I thought you could
have given him more trouble.
He is a controversial figure.
Uh, what he does as you know,
is it takes over a company and
shakes them up, uh, and uh,
and in some cases is accused
of stripping their assets,
but it's all legal and uh, uh, it, it,
you could make an argument that it's
in the general good of our society that
people do that if a company sell,
if it's stock sells for less
than its assets are worth,
then the company may be,
should be broken up and the assets taken
and given somewhere else because the
low, the low stock price indicates
a problem. Uh, I, you know,
I don't know how to evaluate
everything icon has done, but, uh,
some of corporate Raiders
have been unkind to employees.
Uh,
and maybe it's not always the radar,
it's that some employees had trusted
in an implicit contract that they were
offered by their employer.
For example,
the employer may have said verbally
or suggested to an employee that, uh,
you know, if you do well,
we'll promote you up and, uh,
you will have various
advantages in the future.
And then an outside writer comes
in and just fires the employee.
So naturally the employee feels wronged.
Uh,
and there are instances of
that sort of thing. Um, but,
uh, again, it's like anyone
who does important things,
it's hard to judge the
whole picture. And, um,
uh, on net, I f I'm sure he has
created value for the economy.
Um,
so yeah,
someone suggested that we should bring
in corporate regulators. It was you, uh,
as well. Uh, I think maybe
in the next year I'll,
I'll do that to offset and bringing
in a lot of very successful,
um, finance practitioners. And I
don't have any regulators this year.
Uh, also, uh, one of you asked, uh, what,
what literature do you read? And, uh,
he mentioned the Nicco Mackey and ethics,
which I have never read.
I don't know what that
is, but, uh, and he also,
meg mentioned a poem by Rudyard Kipling.
I call if,
uh, and I didn't recognize what
he was referring to immediately,
but I looked it up and it's a,
it's a famous poem that you must've seen.
Uh, so I, uh, written in 1910,
uh, an inspirational poem,
so I put it up on the Classes v two,
not as part of the reading list,
but it's under, uh, uh, resources.
So you can read Kipling. Uh, maybe
he thought of that because it,
uh,
it's really a poem,
which seems to be an a poem of advice
for young people because it ends up the
last line is, you know, the last
line, cause I want to be excited.
What's the last line? Yeah. If you know,
if you follow these instructions, you
will be a man, my son. And so, uh,
that's the motive thought he may
have been in when he talked. Um,
anyway, we have a, our second
midterm exam is on Monday. Uh,
and it will be like the first midterm,
but it will be less,
um,
less mathematical.
This part of the course had less technical
apparatus then the first part of the
course. So it will concentrate on
the middle third of the course.
And Up to this lecture,
uh,
you have to read for Bozi at
Al again carefully because I,
I'm free to take anything,
uh, from the, uh,
uh, key terms and he,
uh, concepts from, uh,
the chapters that were assigned
for this part of the course.
And of course,
every reading that is online,
I don't expect you to go to the library,
uh, is, uh, something I might ask about.
Uh,
and April 11,
we have Stephen Schwarzman coming
and I'm looking forward to that.
That will again be a Friday.
Uh,
but it will be at nine o'clock
and he will be here. Uh,
so, uh, I think that will
be a lot of fun also.
So I wanted to start today's talk a
lecture, which is about monetary policy.
Uh, and, uh,
it's really apropos right now.
Uh,
we are living in very unusual times and
I am sure that Ben Bernanki and other
central bank presidents are losing sleep
right now because this is a time to
challenge monetary policy makers.
Uh,
the thing that really emerged just in
the last week or so is that of course
monetary policy is about
setting up interest rates. Okay.
In the last week,
the treasury bill rate on the United
States four week treasury bills,
which are the standard,
essentially three months,
it fell to 0.2%.
Okay.
This is shocking what,
what is happening now?
Interest rates have hit zero t 0.2%.
That's 20 basis points above zero.
People have long thought that these
kinds of things happen only in Japan.
Uh, but that's not, uh, that's
not true at all. It's happened.
It's happening right now in the u s it
has been a total crash and in a treasury
bill rates. So, uh, uh,
it's not going to add,
one thing we know is that this crash
is over because the treasury building a
three month treasury bill rate has
crashed. It's virtually zero. Uh,
and the story is over because
it can't go any lower. Well,
it could go 20 basis points lower,
but interest rates can never be negative,
right? So that's it. It's
over. We've just hit zero. Uh,
this is the thing that worries central
bankers. When interest rates hit zero,
then they don't have,
it's a little bit like you're a steering
system on your car freezing up or a
hitting a, uh, your hydro
planning on the highway.
Your steering wheel doesn't work anymore
because once interest rates hit zero,
you can't cut them anymore.
And that's what the Fed wants to do.
I'm talking about four weeks,
tertiary bills. The, uh,
the federal funds rate is still
at two and a quarter percent. Uh,
but at least the, the, uh,
the more prominent a three month
t bill rate is, uh, is at the,
at the end. So what I, um,
I want to do is talk about what the Fed
in this country is doing and what other
central banks are doing.
Uh,
but I wanted to start by putting
it in historical perspective. Uh,
and so if you'll allow me, I will, uh,
talk first about just what
is a central bank, uh,
such as the Federal Reserve, uh, and, uh,
and what do they do? So, uh,
I want as the first just go back,
the story I told you in a recent lecture
was a story of a Goldsmith banker.
Okay. This is how it
started. There were people,
Goldsmiths were people who worked in
the metal gold and made beautiful things
for people, jewelry and other things.
And they had safes in their shop.
And some people would say
to the Goldsmith, uh, you
know, I have some valuables.
I don't have a safe, can I put it in your
safe? And the Goldsmith who would say,
okay, and he'd write a little note,
uh, and hand it to the guy and say,
just keep this note. And, uh, if it
was a bearer note, if the note said,
I'll take it. If it wasn't a
unique object, which is gold,
the note would say that this Goldsmith
will pay to the bearer so many ounces of
gold. Uh, and that's how, uh,
banking and got started, uh,
emerged into a institution
in which banks would, uh,
uh, have notes, bank notes,
uh, that circulated widely. Uh,
and we began to think of them as money.
If you put your gold in
the care of a goldsmith,
initially you don't think
you think the money is there,
but eventually you have this bearer note
that you start passing around to spend
to other people and they start
to think of them as money. Uh,
and that's the origin of banking.
So if you ask someone a couple of
hundred years, because years ago,
what's the essence of a bank? They
would say, oh, they print paper money,
private banks,
print paper money,
not just a government back. Well,
there weren't government banks.
They were originally,
they were all private. Uh,
there is a institution
called the gold standard now,
totally and completely gone
everywhere in the world. Uh,
what was it began the first country to
adopt the gold standard officially was
the United Kingdom.
And that was in 1717.
Uh,
and what it meant was,
had the government of the UK was committed
that they're paper money would always
end at all times, be
redeemable in gold. Uh,
it was gradually adopted by
other countries through time. Uh,
and the United States didn't
officially adopted until 1900.
Uh, but, uh, uh,
but, uh, let me just go back to
the, uh, the way the thing work.
It used to be that, uh, it was, uh,
the actually the gold standard kind
of came in by accident in England.
Originally, there was, in the 16 hundreds
prominent coin was called a shilling,
and it was a silver coin.
So the British pound was 20 shillings.
And so effectively the pound
was on a silver standard,
but then they started minting
new coins out of gold.
And the government was issuing
coins, they call them guineas. Uh,
and they started out as a,
they just minted the amount in one coin,
which they thought was equivalent to
20 showings. So they had a Guinea,
which they said was 20 shillings.
Uh, and then there were two coins.
You can either shillings or guineas there.
That was the money at the time.
Uh,
but then the problem was that the price,
relative price of those two was
not really fixed by the government.
And so it started to drift
and people started to think,
I think a Guinea is worth
more than 20 shillings,
and the market price
drifted up to 21 shillings.
And so the government was upset of the UK.
We wanted this to be a 20 shelling coin,
but now in the market it's trading at 21.
So then they implement a rule that
beginning is worth 20,000 shillings.
Uh, then the relative price of gold
versus silver shifted to the point that,
uh, the, uh, the, uh,
gold with the at 21
shilling exchange rate,
the gold showing was worth less.
The Gold Guinea was worth
less than 21 showing.
So all the shellings disappeared.
And the only coin left was the Guinea.
And so England, uh, became,
uh, my gold standard. Uh,
the Bank of England was founded in 1694,
and that is the world's
first central bank. Um,
it was granted a monopoly on
joint stock banking by parliament.
In return for, uh, uh,
giving war loans to the government.
Uh,
it started out as just a powerful bank.
it did not have a government
monopoly on note issue,
but over the time it became
the prime issuer of UK notes.
Now,
what actually developed in the 17 hundreds
is that the bank of England being the
most powerful bank in England started
to demand that other banks in the UK who
were also issuing notes,
uh, would leave there.
W We keep a deposit with the Bank
of England. So the Bank of England,
if you were a little bank somewhere in,
in the UK, the Bank of England would say,
you've got to keep a deposit with us.
Uh,
otherwise we'll destroy you because the
Bank of England good then demand all the,
he can start accumulating notes from
some issuing bank and then demand payment
in gold. Uh, and the issuing bank, uh,
would be driven out of
business if it didn't,
if they all were using
fractional reserve banking.
And so if you have a big player
that's demanding gold from you,
you're in trouble.
So all the banks complied and 10 and
cap deposits with the Bank of England.
So you see what Bank of England
emerged into was a banker's bank.
Okay. You have lots of banks. The banks
are taking and gold and issuing notes,
uh,
but there,
but they are forced by the Bank of
England to keep a deposit at the Bank of
England. Uh, and uh,
so the Bank of England then became a
kind of a regulator of these banks and it
would also loaned to them
when they're in trouble.
They had a relationship between
the Bank of England and so the,
the Bank of England became a
source of stability in the UK.
The problem with private banks issuing
notes is that they would periodically,
uh, be banking crises. Uh,
when the banks failed to pay on their
notes and they couldn't pay up the goal
that was demanded that was required
with a fractional reserve system.
You're in an unstable equilibrium.
If people start to demanding
payment on their notes, then, uh,
then they will destroy the system.
If they did it,
if they start demanding,
uh, then we're in trouble.
So the Bank of England effectively
enforced that, uh, that the,
that the banks in England
cap adequate reserves. Uh,
and,
and they would see these,
some of these reserves in the
deposits at the Bank of England. Uh,
and so England's money was more
stable than in other countries.
Uh, and, uh, uh, in the United States,
we did not have a central bank until
1913 when we created the Federal Reserve
System.
Before that,
the United States went through
repeated banking crises, uh,
when people would start demanding
the goal for their notes. Uh,
and, uh, when did we have, we had a,
a severe banking crisis in the
United States in 1797 in 18,
19 in 1837 in 1857 in 1873 in 1893 and
in 1907 and we just had one after another
where the banking system kept collapsing.
What would happen is there'd be a panic.
People would say they're
not paying on the notes. Uh,
and so everyone would run to the
bank and demand their money and this,
and when that happened, it would
destroy the economy. So it was,
it was a subject of much discussion of
what to do to prevent these bank runs,
uh, in, uh, in the United States.
Uh, and, uh, uh, Massachusetts there,
can you hear me and I've,
I should stay over here. I,
maybe I shouldn't write
on the board. Uh, if, uh,
in the United States in Massachusetts,
a bank called the Suffolk
bank, that's s u f f o, l, k,
uh, created a Little Bank of England
in the state of Massachusetts,
and they created what was
called the Suffolk system, uh,
in 1819. And what the Suffolk
Bank did, is it just on its own,
it just declared that it was the Bank of
England for the state of Massachusetts,
and it required that all banks in the
Boston area keep deposits with them.
Uh, and so the, uh, cell phone
bank became a banker's bank.
Uh, and, uh, it lasted until 1860. Uh,
it then made Massachusetts
the most stable state, uh,
essentially the most stable state in the
country. And it was widely admired. Uh,
thing you have to understand is if you
could go back in a time machine to,
uh, before 1860, uh, in the United States,
you would have real problems
with paper money. Uh,
and you would be very much
aware of the paper money.
If you took out your wallet and looked
at the paper money in your wallet,
it would be issued by lots of different
banks, not any one standard bank.
Okay. If you went to a store to
buy something with paper and money,
the, the person at the, uh, would it
be a cash register? What do they have?
Cash box would be, it would have,
uh, something called van when it was,
it's called van courts.
Um,
banknote reporter and
counterfeit detector.
It was a magazine that would be every,
every retailer would subscribe to it.
And so what the guy would do is
he would say, okay, you've got it.
If it was local money, if it
was from this town, you know,
if it was new haven money
there were in new haven banks,
the guy would immediately
know what it's worth.
But if you were to make the mistake of
trying to spend Boston money in new haven,
they would get out van carts and then
they would read the discount. Uh,
and so Boston money was probably pretty
good because of the Suffolk system.
But if you tried spending New York money
in new haven, they would get out the, uh,
the bank note reporter and give a,
put a discount on it.
So it was a messy system. So you'd only
get like 90 cents on the dollar. Uh,
that's because nobody trusted these banks.
There was,
they could go under any day,
and so they tended to sell at a discount.
So, uh, uh,
and so though the u s did create what
sounded like central bank because they
were the first bank of the United States,
uh,
and the Second Bank of the United States,
the First Bank of the United
States was created in 1791.
Uh, and, uh, it had a 20 year charter,
which expired in 1811.
Uh,
and it wasn't immediately renewed because
the United States got into a war that
we call the war of 1812.
It was the u s connection
to the Napoleonic wars.
So it wasn't until after the war that we
created a new bank of the United States
in 18, 16, and it gave it a 20
year charter as well. Uh, so,
but those were not central banks
because they, uh, uh, these,
uh,
we have a correction of our
microphone problem. Lost it
again. I have my microphone on.
It's just that it's, they say it's
not working or it's not loud enough.
Oh, it is working. All right.
Yeah,
but you still can't hear me when
I stand over here. All right. Um,
okay. There was a, in the United States,
we created the national banking
system in 1863 after a banking crisis.
And, uh, that worked fairly well.
Instead of having a central bank,
we decided that there would be a list
of bank called the national banks,
uh,
and uh,
and the national banks would be required
to help bail out any bank that was
failing. Uh, and so it was
something like a central bank,
but it was different essentially in that
the national banks really didn't have
the authority to run monetary policy.
They merely where they're in a term
in a time of emergency to prevent,
hopefully a banking crisis.
Uh, and they didn't succeed.
We still had banking crises, so the
system didn't seem to work very well.
The 1907 banking crisis then led finally
to the creation of the system that we
have now, the Federal Reserve
System. Uh, and what it was,
was in many ways an effort to bring the
Bank of England to the United States.
They wouldn't have said that
because it doesn't sound,
we want to think that
we invented this here,
but it actually was a new invention
in a way because the United States,
uh, has a different philosophy, uh,
which is the United States has been
committed over since it's beginning to
federalism. That is they don't
want, uh, or more broadly,
they don't want centralization of
power in the government. And so the,
instead of setting up a central
bank in the United States,
as was done commonly in other countries,
the United States
instead created 12 banks.
They're the 12 federal reserve banks.
That was an effort to disperse
power away from the center. Uh,
the idea was that,
uh,
power to the people in rather
than the central government. Uh,
and, uh, this,
the Federal Reserve system
that was created in 1913
was different in that it was
independent or a much more independent
than central banks and other countries.
Other countries had set
up central banks, uh, uh,
following on the Bank of England.
But the U s didn't set up a central bank.
It's set up a system of 12
banks and they were regional.
And the idea was that this is better.
It's more democratic.
Each region of the United
States has its own, uh,
it's own bank.
And the banks were not technically
government institutions,
whether they're semi government.
It's kind of strange set up. The,
uh,
the Federal Reserve banks are
owned not by the government,
but by the banks in this
region where they operate.
They're called member banks.
So banks that become a member of the
Federal Reserve System get shares and they
become stockholders in the Federal
Reserve Bank and they get dividends should
work now. Okay. Does it
work now? Can I walk away?
Wonderful. Okay. Thank you. Um, but,
but they're not traded there no price
per share that you can observe. A,
and the banks can't do anything except
passively received the dividend,
but they can also participate in choosing
the directors and the president of the
Federal Reserve banks. Uh, okay.
So that's a very dispersed system,
but it still works because
member banks create,
keep deposits at the Federal
Reserve Banks, uh, and,
uh,
they're required to keep these deposits.
And moreover they can also borrow from
the Federal Reserve banks when they need,
when they're in trouble and need money,
and that's supposed to help
prevent a banking crises. Uh,
so, um, that's the Federal
Reserve system. Incidentally,
there's 12 banks and there's 12 districts.
Uh,
the districts back in 1913 are represented
the population distribution of the u
s at that time. So, uh,
there's a lot more districts in the east
coast of the u s than the west coast.
There's also to the Federal Reserve
banks in once in a state of Missouri, uh,
both as,
uh,
the Federal Reserve Bank of Kansas City
and the Federal Reserve Bank of St Louis.
So you wonder why would it be that the
whole western half of the u s gets only,
or the western third of the U s gets
only 1 cent, one Federal Reserve Bank.
That's Saint San Francisco.
But Missouri gets to, well,
that's kind of political
history. Uh, it's kind of absurd,
but that's the way it is. Um, the,
the real difference,
uh,
between the Federal Reserve
Bank system of 1913,
the most important difference and the
Federal Reserve System of today is that we
are no longer on the gold standard.
Uh,
the Federal Reserve System was a gold
standard institution like the Bank of
England. It was supposed to, uh,
maintain the converted [inaudible]
of the currency into gold.
Okay.
So under the gold standard,
your dollar bill represented so many
ounces of gold and you are supposed to be
able to always get that gold.
That means you could go to a bank and
demand gold and the bank then could go to
the Federal Reserve and get gold for it.
Uh,
that was the system.
The gold standard was at success in
the sense that the price of gold stayed
constant because that's what the
whole system was dying designed to do.
There's a famous story about
Irving Fisher, who was a
professor here at Yale, uh,
Hu,
uh,
remarking on how few people
understand the gold standard.
I don't know if I'm repeating this, but
he was at his dentist. They tell you,
I didn't tell you this.
He was at his dentist and they used
to give gold fillings in those days.
And he said to the dentist, he
said, just out of curiosity,
can you tell me what the
price of gold has? You know,
what it's been doing lately?
Uh, and the dentist said, Gee, I don't
know. I'll, I'll look at my records.
I have some old records and
I'll see what I was paying for,
for my goals for the gold
fillings 10 years ago.
And the dentist came back and said,
funny thing, it hasn't changed at all.
I'm paying exactly what
I did 10 years ago. Uh,
Irving Fisher then told that story
as an illustration of how poorly the
understanding is of what's going on.
Of course,
the price of gold never changed in the
gold standard because that was the whole
point of the gold standard, that the
currency was convertible in the goal.
But what happened in the 1930s is that
one country after another abandoned the
gold standard.
Uh,
and the United Kingdom was
the prominent first case.
Even though they had invented the gold
standard hundreds of years earlier.
In 1931, they dropped to
convert ability of the pound.
Sterling is still called pounds sterling,
even though it's not silver,
it was gold. Uh, they, they
dropped the pound comfortability.
Uh, the United States
dropped it in 1933. Uh,
and other countries did it later.
The reason they countries dropped
the gold standard is that under the,
uh,
effort to keep the currency
convertible into gold,
they were worsening the
depression of the 1930s. Uh,
in order to keep the currency convertible,
they had to keep interest rates high to
prevent people from demand demanding the
gold and keeping interest rates.
How I was was destroying the economy.
Uh,
and so the gold standard ended in the
1930s and every country dropped it.
But we're left with the central banking
institutions that are now functioning
without convert ability
to goals. Um, and uh,
so, uh, there then you
start to wonder, well,
what is the system and what
does it supposed to do?
The old gold standard was supposed to
maintain the converter ability of gold and
currency, but now we're not even
backing it with currency anymore.
It was gold anymore. So
what does it mean? Um,
well, what it means is
that starting in the 1930s,
we began to think of central
banks as managing the money stock,
uh, to, um,
managing the money stock to stabilize
the economy. And that's what,
that's the view that's developed
and has been with us ever since.
Uh,
they still hold gold.
And right now the Federal Reserve
system has about $11 billion of gold.
All right?
They still have it when we remember
what happened in 1933 is they abandoned
convertibility with gold,
right?
So that means that you no longer
have the right to get it. Uh,
but uh, uh, that doesn't mean
they don't still own gold.
It's just sitting there in
their vaults from way back.
Uh, so some people ask what
is the currency backed by?
And it used to be backed by gold.
There's the question of what it means
to say something is backed by something.
Uh, because, uh, uh, just speak,
you could say it's backed by gold because
if the Fed has $11 billion of gold,
all right. And that's a lot less
than the amount of money out there,
but they always had fractional
reserve banking anywhere.
They never kept all the goal for
all the dollars that they issued.
So you could say it's
still backed by gold.
The really important thing is it's
not convertible into gold. All right.
And so since 1933,
the Fed has been managing an inflation.
It used to be that there was zero
inflation if you define it with respect to
gold.
And they were really true to that
zero inflation in terms of gold.
Now there was inflation with regard to
a basket of the consumer price index is
not just the price of gold, it's the
price of of many things. But the,
uh, the, uh,
there will be inflation or deflation
as the relative price of gold changed.
But after 1933,
we had lost our moorings.
There was no longer any idea that
the dollar was backed by anything.
The concept changed.
Fundamentally,
the concept that became
the Federal Reserve or the
central banks in any country
are managing the economy and the, uh, the,
their management of the
money supply is, uh, is,
um,
is there a way of managing
how well things go?
Generally,
it has been inflationary once we,
after 1933,
central banks have generally gradually,
uh,
allowed prices to rise.
And the general view is that if it's not,
it's not extreme.
Uh,
the rise is not too extreme.
It's good for the health of the economy
as long as we don't have inflation
that's too high.
Uh,
and so central banks
around the world began to,
uh, manage, uh,
became managers of inflation
rather than defenders of,
of a gold standard. Let me just mention
a couple of other central banks.
The Bank of England has been providing
an example for the world for a long time.
Uh,
the Bank of Japan was established in
imitation of the Bank of England in 1882.
Um, the, uh, uh,
the many central banks in Europe,
they except go back to
the 18th or 19th century.
Uh, some banks, however, are very
new. The European Central Bank,
which,
um,
issues the euro currency
I was founded in 1998,
so it's only 10 years old.
Uh,
that's because it replaced central banks
of the member countries of the European
Union.
The central banks still exist.
So you still have the Bank of France,
the butcher, Bundesbank, et Cetera,
but they no longer have the importance
that they once did because they no longer
manage a currency.
The currency is centralized
at the European Central Bank.
Uh,
one thing that's been a trend
around the world is that the,
I mentioned that the US Federal Reserve
system was different from other central
banks in that it was designed
to have independence. Uh,
the thought was that the central bank
is guy is guarding the money stock and
governments have a tendency to sometimes
to want to raid the back when they're
in trouble.
Typically it happened during wars
or government gets into a war.
Okay? During the war, the
government needs resources.
It's in trouble.
It raises taxes to try to pay for the war,
but then it finds that unable
to collect taxes as well.
People start evading taxes.
There's a lot of discord.
It's just hard to raise money by taxing.
So what the government would do is send
someone over to the central bank and say,
Hey, expand, expand.
Give us, lend us money.
You're the central bank lenders money.
Uh,
and so the central bank would print up
notes and give it to the government and
the government would start spending
it on the war. Uh, and so, uh,
uh, then you'd have inflation because
they're printing all this money.
So war time periods were typically periods
of great inflation and debasement of
the currency. Uh, and so, uh,
that's why we need independence
of the central bank.
We want to have a central banker
that can say no to the government.
So the government comes to the bank and
says, it's a war. We needed the money.
And the central bank would ideally say,
no,
how can you get a central
banker to do that? Well,
they definitely have to be
independent of the government.
And that was the idea in
the u s so there's been a
trend to making central banks
more independent.
And there are particular
things that happened in Japan.
In 1997,
the government of Japan granted
the Bank of Japan independence,
uh, like the u s uh, uh, central bank.
And so, uh, it also happened
in the UK in the same year.
Uh, now I've been describing the Bank
of England as the model for everyone,
but in fact,
the Bank of England was
not independent until 1997.
Uh, and now these, these people
are the people who run these banks.
They, there may still be
appointed by the government,
but they have terms of office,
uh,
that are lengthy and the government
can't kick the central had head of the
Central Bank for failing to offer
them loans when they want it.
So in the United States, uh, we
have 12 federal reserve banks,
but we have a federal
open market committee,
the Federal Reserve Board in Washington
organizers policy for all 12 banks.
Uh, and the, uh,
members of the Federal Reserve
Board have 14 year terms. Uh,
plus all the presidents of the Federal
Reserve banks come and serve on something
called the Federal Open Market Committee.
Uh,
and the Federal Open Market
Committee makes monetary policy.
So it's decentralized
and long terms. The, uh,
the board members have 14 year terms,
which is quite a long time, uh,
and the central.
And also there are the banks
from the regional banks that uh,
uh, that, uh, have,
uh,
also a role for the federal open market
committee meets about every six weeks or
so. And they decide on
monetary policy. Uh,
in fact they decided on how
to, uh, set interest rates, uh,
and borrowing requirements
for member banks.
One of the things that the Federal Reserve
does is it sets reserve requirements
for banks.
Reserve requirements are like what the
Bank of England did or the Suffolk Bank
did long ago.
It says that you have to keep deposits
with us here at the central bank,
either either that or us keep VOP cash,
uh,
and [inaudible] sure that you
have it as reserves for, uh,
uh,
for your deposit.
Now these banks no longer issue notes.
We've centralized the note issue in the
United States starting in 1913 with the
Federal Reserve Board.
So your notes that you see are
called Federal Reserve notes. Uh,
but bank still are vulnerable to bank
runs because they still have deposits.
And so the system is still vulnerable and
that therefore the Federal Reserve has
a step up, a set of
reserve requirements. Uh,
now the reserve requirement,
it's progressive.
Small banks have lower
reserve requirements,
but it rapidly gets up to a standard.
And so the reserve requirement now is 10%,
uh,
on demand deposits. So, uh,
they're are forced to keep
those reserves. Uh, and, uh, uh,
much of that is in the form of
deposits at the Federal Reserve banks.
So one,
one form of monetary policy that the Fed
does is they can change these reserve
requirements.
The other,
but more commonly used monetary
policy is to change the rate is to,
uh, effectively, uh,
alter the rate of interest on deposits.
So the interest rate,
uh, the, the, the, the, uh,
policy tool in the United States,
the policy interest rate or key rate in
the United States is called the federal
funds rate.
And the federal funds rate is an
overnight lending rate between banks.
The Federal Reserve conducts monetary
policy by targeting the federal funds
rate.
Uh,
and it announces since 1994 it has been
announcing after the meetings or the
Federal Open Market Committee,
it's been announcing the,
uh, uh, federal funds rate,
uh, publicly. Uh,
so the federal funds rate
was recently cut to 2.25%.
Uh,
and it's like,
it's expected to be cut further
because of the recession that we're now
apparently in. Uh, and
so that will be the, um,
that will be the monetary policy took
what's happening right now in the United
States is that the economy is collapsing.
Maybe that's overstating it's contracting.
Uh,
and so the Fed is trying to prevent a
serious recession by cutting interest
rates. And so they've been
cutting them rapidly. Uh, and, uh,
the federal funds rate is a rate that
is targeted by the Fed and it's their
principle target.
Uh,
the federal funds rate is the rate that
banks borrow and lend to each other over
night. Um, uh,
there's another interest rate that the
Fed sets and that's called the discount
rate. Uh, and, um, the, um,
um,
the discount rate
is the rate that the Fed charges
for loans to member banks.
The
member banks just as with the or the
Bank of England when they're in trouble,
they're supposed to be able to
borrow money from the central bank.
Okay. And the central bank
posts an interest rate that, uh,
that is the rate at which
these member banks can borrow.
Uh,
the,
there was an important change
in the discount rate in January,
uh,
of 2003.
It used to be that the Fed would
grant loans to member banks,
uh, in the form of discount
rate, low lending. Uh,
if the, uh, bank could certify
that it was in trouble,
uh,
and uh,
at that time they would give generous
loan. This is before 2003, the,
the discount rate was it policy variable
set by the Fed and it was typically 50
basis points below the federal funds rate.
Okay.
They're lending to banks that
were in trouble and the, uh,
so we'll give them a good rate.
That's what they used to do.
In 2003,
they decided to change that and they
decided to raise the discount rate above
the, uh, uh, the, uh,
federal funds rate. And so they do
actually, there's two discount rates.
There's primary and secondary.
The primary discount rate is typically
a hundred basis points above the funds
rate. Um, and uh,
that's not so recently they've
been cutting it to that, but that,
that was originally the idea.
So they,
in what they wanted to
do in starting in 2003,
is to eliminate the idea that the
discount rate is only for banks who are in
trouble.
They wanted to eliminate the stigma.
It used to be embarrassing to borrow
at the discount window because, uh,
the discount rate would,
uh,
because it would be s admission
that the bank is in trouble. Uh,
and so in order to try to eliminate that
stigma, they made it a penalty rate.
It made the discount rate higher than
the, uh, than the federal funds rate.
So now the federal funds rate
is at two and a quarter percent.
The discount rate is now
only 25 basis points higher.
It's at two and a half percent.
Uh,
they've been cutting the spread between
the discount rate and the federal funds
rate. Again, it's an effort
to stimulate the, uh,
I think one reason why they may have
changed it in 2003 is that interest rates,
we're getting really
close to zero in 2003.
And they were worried that if the
discount rate is 50 basis points below the
federal funds rate, then it's going to
hit zero. And that would be embarrassing.
So they moved it.
I think that might be the reason
that no one knows what they're,
all their reasons were. Uh, so, um,
so the,
the,
the basic idea that's developed is that
the Fed is looking at inflation and
unemployment as the two major
things that it looks at.
Inflation is, is the most important
thing and according to many views,
because the fed has to guarantee the
soundness of the, of the money supply.
And there've been so many cases in
history when the central bank allowed
debasement of the currency
through inflation. Uh,
and it's thought that that is a serious
error because it destroys trust in the
currency.
On the other hand,
the Fed is also concerned
with unemployment and the
possibility of a collapse in
the system. So right now the
Fed is in a difficult situation.
Last year we had 4% inflation,
4% inflation is high by,
uh,
by traditional standards.
It's above what we'd like.
We'd like it to be more like 2%,
4% is high.
And so that would mean that the Fed
should be raising interest rates to try to
tighten up the economy and
bring the inflation rate down.
But unfortunately, we are in this
collapse situation in the economy.
Uh, and so the Fed has a problem
with this. There's a name for this,
it's called stagflation stagflation was
a term that was developed in the 1970s
to refer to a time when inflation is,
we have both high inflation
and high unemployment.
And so we're in that
situation apparently again.
So with interest rates
hitting zero, uh, Alan,
I said Alan Greenspan, then Bernanki
must be losing sleep at night.
This is exactly the worst
nightmare of a central banker.
You've got this policy tool of
interest rate, but once it hits zero,
you're, you're, you're out of business.
So he has been working on trying to
find other tools of monetary policy.
Yeah. Uh, uh,
Ben Bernanki has been
very creative in doing it.
Maybe I write some of these things down.
Uh,
the term auction facility,
our TAF
was created,
uh, by the Federal Reserve, uh,
under Bernanki on December 12th.
And so, uh, it's a new
form of monetary policy,
a new invention, which we've been
doing only for a matter of months. Now,
what the term auction facility,
it was also created in connection in
collaboration with the Bank of Canada,
the Bank of England, the European Central
Bank, and the Swiss National Bank.
So we're seeing an internationalization
of bank monetary policy.
All of these central banks
of Canada, England, Europe,
and Switzerland got together with
the Federal Reserve and said the,
obviously they were worried about the
financial crisis that was in golfing in
the world.
And so they agreed to auction off.
Uh,
it's a little bit
different than a, um, uh,
it's a little different from an
ordinary monetary policy as a way of,
of, uh, helping troubled
financial institutions. Uh,
so what they did,
instead of just remember the,
the federal funds rate is a target
interest rate that the Fed attempts to hit
through buying and selling treasury
bills in the u s or in other countries,
buying and selling government
bonds to affect the market.
If the Fed wants to push
the federal funds rate down,
it goes and buys short
term government bonds.
Buying them tends to push up the price
that tends to influence the yield down.
And so it encourages a lower
level of interest rate. Uh,
but the term auction facility
is different in this facility.
Uh, banks are allowed to, uh,
the Fed announces a certain amount of
money that it wants to put out there,
uh, in, uh,
in the form of a collateralized loans,
uh,
with, uh, uh, other banks,
uh, w with member banks.
Uh,
and so what the Fed said it would do is,
is announced an auction,
a of so many billion
dollars of, uh, of, uh,
uh,
loans to a member banks and the banks
have to supply collateral to the Federal
Reserve.
The collateral could be a number of
things including a mortgage and securitize
mortgages that are risky
and dangerous, uh, assets.
Uh,
and so in effect,
the Fed is trying to solve the subprime
crisis by taking on as collateral,
uh,
some of these risky things in
exchange for offering a low
loans to um, uh, a member bank.
And it's different from fed policy in
that they set up an a certain amount of
money in auction that off
to the highest bidder.
And so troubled banks then who have this
si the problem banks have now is they
have these,
these securitized mortgages that they
bought and the homeowners are defaulting
on the is now.
Uh,
and so there was a panic in the
market for securitized mortgages.
And so the price is often very low,
or if it's there,
they're very hard to
market, hard to sell. Uh,
and so banks are in trouble.
And as you know,
they're starting to fail because they,
they're,
the value of their assets in
the market is falling rapidly.
So the Fed is effectively just saying,
we'll take those assets as
collateral for loans to,
uh, and so, uh, they've
given out, as of today,
it's 80 billion, uh, on the term.
So this thing is,
this new invention is three
months old at this point.
Um,
but the system continues
to look more for curious.
And so, uh, this is a very
interesting time because, uh,
the Fed is, um, is continuing to invent.
So then they came up with the
term securities
loan facility.
Uh,
and don't look this up in for Bozi,
uh,
because the date of
founding was march 11 2008.
That's actually the date that
they announced it. Uh, and uh, uh,
what they're going to do is
have auctions of loans of,
of
Treasury securities in exchange for
collateral such as mortgage securities.
And the first auction is
first auction is March
27,
2008,
which you may know is tomorrow.
Um,
actually I mentioned the term securities
loan facility because it's a new
innovation,
but it hasn't started yet.
So in their announcement on march 11,
they said the Fed would
land up to 200 billion,
uh,
of securities to the market.
What they're really doing is just the,
we're facing the seize up
of our financial system.
So we have banks that we've just
seen the failure of bear Sterns,
which is actually a broker dealer.
But, uh, banks and broker dealers, uh,
are in trouble because their assets are
collapsing under them and they can't
sell them. They get
money. So the Fed is fine.
We'll just take those and we'll give you
a treasury bills, which are completely,
no, everyone trusts them. So you
had some assets that nobody trusts.
The US Federal Reserve will take it on.
Uh,
uh, and this is an effort. This is
different from most monetary policy.
Uh,
now it's different
in important ways because it's really
focused at preventing the collapse of the
economy that is created by
financial system failure.
Uh, and, uh,
so it's looking at the problem that
certain troubled institutions have that
their assets can't be sold. Um, and, um,
and it's just saying,
okay,
well what are we placing them with
assets that can be sold? The Fed is Tate,
he's taking on serious risk in doing this,
uh,
because these assets that it takes on in
exchange for Treasury securities could
fail. Nobody knows how bad the
mortgage crisis is going to get,
but Ben Bernanki thinks that
it's so important, uh, that we,
um, uh, that we, uh, prevented collapse,
that we should, uh, we
should take that risk.
Incidentally, both of these
things, this is called the ts
and this is called the test.
Both of these are joint with
the Fed in the United States,
the ECB, the Bank of England, uh,
and the Swiss Bank and Dental Canada.
So these are all international efforts
to s to forestall of financial crisis.
Uh, there's a third
one, uh, which, uh, uh,
is even newer. Well, it's, it
made, this one was announced.
The third innovation is called
the primary
dealers
credit facility.
Uh,
and that was announced March 16,
2008, so that's how many
days ago, a few days ago,
10 days ago. Uh, and that's called the p,
the c f. Uh, and, uh,
what the PDC of is,
is really an extension of the
discount window beyond member backs.
Uh, and you have to know
what our primary dealers, uh,
and, uh, primary dealers
are broker dealers.
They are not banks.
Uh,
the critical thing that's happening is
that at a time of financial crisis with
which exceeds any that we've seen
perhaps since the Great Depression,
uh, but certainly bigger than
we've seen in many years,
the Fed is worrying about
not just member banks,
but also other financial institutions.
For example,
bear Stearns, which is
a broker dealer, uh,
failed recently,
uh,
and the Fed is worried about
it collapsing house of cards.
So what's essential about the prime
primary dealers credit facility is that
they're opening up the discount window
lending beyond the member banks to
primary dealers.
So what does a primary dealer,
when the Treasury in the United
States sells treasury bills,
notes and bonds?
They deal almost exclusively,
but I would say primarily
with broker dealers,
not the general public.
Okay.
So the Federal Reserve has a list which
you can find on their website of dealers
who are eligible to participate
in treasury security auctions.
There's 20 acts that I'm
not sure there's 20 anymore.
One of them was bear Stearns.
Uh,
and so I don't know whether they're
still on the list. Maybe they are,
maybe they're not.
We might have be down to 19,
but these are broker dealers and some
of them are international, like BNB.
Powerbar is one of them. It's,
it's French. Uh, and so, uh,
by opening up the primary
dealers credit facility, we are,
we are,
what the government is offering to do is
to take bad investments that they made
on as collateral for loans at
two and a half percent, uh,
which is the current, uh,
uh, discount rate. Uh,
so this is quite a remarkable change
reflecting the seriousness of the crisis.
Uh, and, uh, so, um,
uh,
so I think,
and it's reflecting the fact that we're
moving into possibly a situation, uh,
of a protracted situation of,
of nearly zero interest rates
and an effort to get more, uh,
to keep the economy from a collapsing,
uh,
at a time when, um, uh,
at a time of great, uh, uh,
concern about the structure
of the financial system.
This is different than other recessions.
We've had other economic problems,
uh,
that have led to recessions, but it
hasn't seemed to be something as, uh,
as potentially global, uh, as it is
now. You know, we had the, uh, uh,
savings and loan crisis of the 1980s
and in the savings and loan crisis.
It was a certain segment
of the banking community,
the SNLs that seem to be in trouble,
but it didn't seem to be then a house
of cards that could spread around, uh,
around the country and around the world.
Um,
in 1998, there was the Russian default
crisis and then there was a, um,
there were some seize up,
uh,
that maybe resembles what were happening.
It's happening now.
Long term capital management
was a big, uh, uh,
a hedge fund that failed in 1998
and got billed out by the Fed.
Um,
but I didn't see then the,
the proliferation of
these new instruments, uh,
that,
uh,
reflects concerns about the
current economic situation.
So I think, uh, maybe the
concluding lesson in that,
that the central banks were institutions
that emerged out of experience with
bankers. It started not
really as a plan system, uh,
not planned by any government.
The Bank of England was its own bank and
the Suffolk Bank was its own bank and
they develop ways of doing business,
uh,
without government planning,
to help try to preserve
stability of the system. Uh,
there've been fundamental changes through
time that make the role of the central
bank, uh, evolve and change through time.
So I know I mentioned earlier that we
used to be on the gold standard and
central banks were gold
standard institutions that
were trying to stabilize the
economy, but subject to the
constraint that they had to maintain,
convert ability with gold. Uh, and, uh,
but those central banks,
uh,
raw has changed a lot of the,
it seems like the nature of
recessions is always changing. Um,
the, uh, the biggest risk,
the biggest recession we've had since
the Great Depression, uh, was the, um,
it was actually a pair
of recession, uh, in, um,
there was every, a short
recession in 1980. Uh,
it's lasted just a few months. Uh,
and people once got out of that,
people thought maybe we're
getting a brief, a respite,
but then in the u s crashed into a huge,
well,
actually it was a worldwide recession
of 1981,
two,
and this was the biggest recession
since the great depression.
What caused that recession?
Uh,
I think there's a simple story which is
very different from what's causing the
current,
uh,
apparently current recession in
19 in the 1960s and seventies.
Central banks around the world.
We're inflating the currency. Uh,
it was getting out of proportion.
We had inflation rates in the United
Kingdom and the order of 20% a year,
and people were asking what is going on
in the UK bashed and have enlightenment?
What's going on. So they, uh, they
elected Margaret Thatcher, uh, and,
uh, uh, there was a resolve
to do something about it,
but it wasn't just the UK.
It was all over the world. Inflation rates
had gotten very high, even in Germany,
uh, where anti-inflammation
sentiment was the highest.
And so central banks around this time
was,
I think it was under the
leadership of Paul Volcker,
who is Federal Reserve chairman.
They raised interest rates
to kill inflation and they
throw the world into the
huge recession. So, um, what
was, what, what caused it?
It was caused, if it, maybe
it's over simplifying, uh,
it was caused by a change in our resolve
to let this get inflation under control
and a willingness to accept the recession
to stop the advance of inflation.
You can blame it on other things
like the oil crisis of 1979.
Nothing is completely
simple. But anyway, this is,
this recession has been a model
for what happens in recessions.
And the idea that emerged this,
uh,
the memory of the 81 82 recession is very
strong and our imagination because we
think that it was caused
by lax monetary policy,
by liberal thinking,
by the soft hearted liberals who just
didn't want to create any pain and
suffering. And I'm talking about
the view that's commonplace.
And so we finally got tough. We
got Paul Volcker in there, uh, and,
uh,
central banks around the world all managed
to get tough around that time and we
killed inflation. Uh, but
it created a recession.
That's what happened in 81 82. But you
have to remember that times are different.
Subsequent recession.
We're not like that.
So we had another recession in 1990 91,
and it wasn't very big or bad.
Uh,
this recession was, I think,
just a Gulf war recession.
It was caused by, uh, well,
partly by an oil price spike because
by sedan, the war against it.
I'm who's saying? Uh, but
it was also caused by just a
general lack of confidence,
right? It wasn't caused by the Fed
suddenly tightening against inflation.
Uh, it was different. It was, um, it
was, this recession was not understood,
not anticipated.
The Fad Camian lake to cut interest
rates to try to prevent it from getting
worse cause it just didn't seem
to have any reason for happening.
It just surprised everyone.
So it was not a repeat of this.
And then we started 2001 recession.
That recession again is different.
And I think the 2001 if you
want to tell a story about it,
at the 2001 recession was caused by
the end of the stock market. Boom.
We had a bubble in the stock market in
the 1990s and it collapsed after 2000 and
without it brought the economy down,
the Fed they,
and again cut interest rates in 2001 in
response to the very definite weakness
of the economy.
And then that brings us
to the 2008 recession.
Now it's still hasn't been
identified as a recession and,
and some people are still hoping that
we won't have a recession in 2008.
Uh, but I think it's really
looking like we are in a recession.
Notably there's different indicators.
The one that just came out is
the consumer confidence index,
which was a conference board publication
that indeck is now a way below the
lowest that it got in the 2001 recession.
All right.
And it's out the level almost down
to the lowest that we got in the 1990
[inaudible] 91 recession. So I, you know,
that by that indicator we are in a
recession and we don't know that it's over
yet.
It's been falling a home.
Prices are falling at the highest threat
we've ever seen. You know, I have,
my own index is the standard
and poor case Shiller indexes.
And we announced our indexes yesterday.
We saw record price declines and a monthly
basis for 14 of our 20 cities that we
reported. That means that
they've never declined, uh,
as much in one month
before. He said, well,
our data started in 1987.
I have a, I don't have,
we don't have data on
individual city basis,
but it really looks like the housing
collapse price collapse that we're going
through now is a,
uh,
an American to not paralleled since
the Great Depression of the 1930s.
Uh, so, um, uh, I,
I think that we are in
a difficult situation,
but maybe it's not a panic about the,
the optimistic thing is I think that
we have a very good fed chairman,
uh,
and we have coordinated efforts by
central banks around the world and we're
doing things that, uh, uh,
our attempts to prevent the collapse
of the financial institutions.
I think we're still in
a precarious situation,
but I think we do have central bankers
who are working effectively given the
tools that they have. Now.
Incidentally, I, I'm writing a book. Uh,
the title of the book is Sub
Prime Solution. Uh, and, uh,
I just sent it off the draft
to the copy editor last Friday.
So, um, uh, the book,
my publisher, Princeton
University Press, uh,
wants to get it out before
this crisis is over. And so
we've got them on a rush to try to get
the book out and they're thinking that,
uh, we'll at least have
copies to reviewers by June.
And I've been worrying that my book
will be too late and that by, by June,
everything will be rosy
there, lovey over. Uh,
I guess I should hope that
that happens. Uh, but, uh,
I have a suspicion that come June,
uh,
this crisis will not be
over. Unfortunately. Some of
you are on the job market,
uh, this year. Uh, and I, I want to
give you, uh, some constellation,
uh, if, um, if you are not, uh,
had a great success so far
in finding a finance job,
the cancellation is they're
killing people at the top too.
And so they're going to,
and so when you do get a job
in a financial institution,
there'll be more spaces above you
on the ladder to move up. Okay.
Uh, that I think that kind of, uh, uh,
jokingly, but I think, um,
I think you are facing over rather
different if you're on the job market,
you are facing a difficult economy. And,
uh, but, uh, I'm sure that the ule emerge.
All right.
In the long run.